if you seated everyone ready to proceed
that
i did hear from my staff uh staff that
one of the jurors was having some issues
seeing because of the
barrier in a
way all right
if that happens again just raise your
hand and uh we'll we'll have it
maneuvered unfortunately as part of the
covert protocols that they have to be in
court
because i've allowed the attorneys and
the defendant to proceed without wearing
a mask because they're on trial and
they're constantly talking and things of
that nature so because of that
we had to put those up all right i
apologize all right go ahead mr blancas
thank you
dr simmering uh do you have an opinion
to a degree of medical probability as to
what uh michael barrasson's state of
mind was
at the time of the incident yes
he was psychotic and out of touch with
reality
and was he delusional
yes
psychotic actually means out of touch
with reality so psychotic and out of
touch with reality is the same thing
they're different ways to be out of
touch with reality specifically he was
delusional he harbored a series of
interconnected false beliefs which
guided his thinking and his actions
and what did
with those respect to those delusions
what did he believe
was going to happen to him he believed
that lauren canorack and her associates
had come up with an elaborate plan to
destroy him and kill him
is there anything else with regards to
your opinion
and i refer to page 18
just the second diagnosis of chronic
depression persistent depressive
disorder this has been observed by
his therapist by other people in the
past that there is an underlying
depression
did he know the difference between right
and wrong
i'm sorry could you know the difference
between right and wrong
are you talking at the time of the
incident
time of the incident he did not know
he thought he was acting in self-defense
do you understand the nature and quality
of his acts not clear
nothing
all right uh members of the jury before
we get the cross-examination by mr
shellhorn i do want to give you some
certain limited instructions
based on the testimony
you just heard dr simmering of course
was qualified as an expert witness
you've heard that charge from me twice
already you're going to hear it again at
the end when i give my final charge to
you so i'm not going to repeat it
a third time now and then have to do it
a fourth time i trust you will call that
charge regarding uh expert opinion and
their ability to render their opinions
based on information provided to them
and in that regard you have heard
reference to alleged statements made by
the defendant in the course of the
psychiatric examination by dr simran
these are considered hearsay statements
but they are allowed in this
circumstance
you should not consider these here
states uh hearsay statements as
substantive evidence relating to the
guilt or innocence of the defendant
or for the truth of the matter asserted
by the defendant in the statement
rather i instruct you to consider these
statements only
for the limited purpose of explaining or
supporting the conclusions reached by dr
simmering
or for assessing the value of the
doctor's opinions that are dependent or
rely on the defendant's statements
additionally
i believe you heard a
reference from the doctor with regard to
the prior alleged criminal history of
lauren canorack
and mr goodwin
you have heard testimony about
a background check that was done by an
investigator hired by the defendant
the prior criminal history
is
a purported one it's unverified
the defendant alleges that this
information had an impact on his mental
condition
and the testimony was only admissible
and to be only considered by you for
this limited purpose
of explaining or supporting the
conclusions reached by dr simmering or
for assessing the value of the doctor's
opinions that are dependent or rely
on misinformation under our rules of
evidence
a jury may consider a witness's criminal
conviction
determining the credibility or
believability of that witness
we are not here dealing with criminal
convictions
of miss cataract or mr goodwin
there are allegations of prior arrests
those are not
under our rules admissible
with regard to the credibility of miss
cataract or mr goodwin and they were not
admitted for that purpose they are only
admitted
because of the impact that information
may have had on
the state of mind of
the defendant when he received and
reviewed that information that is the
only reason that evidence was admissible
it is not substantive evidence
of the bad character of miss canorack or
mr goodwin it's not in any way admitted
for that purpose and cannot be used by
you and your deliberations for that
purpose
the only relevance of the evidence
is the extent to which you may find it
affected
the mental status or mental condition of
the defendant that's it
there was also testimony similarly about
firearms and possession of weapons
um by miss canorack referred to during
dr simmons testimony again this
information is admitted for a limited
purpose only
as to the state of mind of the defendant
and how it may have affected his state
of mind that information is not
introduced because it may reflect in any
way the bad character of miss cataract
that's not the purpose of it all right
it's only limited information
either explaining or supporting the
conclusions of dr simmering or for
assessing the value of the doctor's
opinions that are dependent or relied
upon that information all right so with
those limiting instructions i'll charge
you again later at the end of the case
on the limits of
evidence but i wanted to do that now
before cross-examination since you have
heard the testimony from dr simran
alright with that we'll begin the
cross-examination by the state
thank you honor
good morning dr summers good morning mr
shellhorn
do you ever use psychological tests as
part of your examination process
yes but i don't perform them
if i need if i think psychological tests
are helpful i will
call upon a psychologist colleague to
perform the testing and you'd agree with
me that even when you do use a
psychological test you would never
render a diagnosis based on the test no
i would not
now you indicated uh on direct
examination that you
rendered your diagnoses
using the dsm correct i'm just going to
refer to it that way i think at this
point now the jury knows what we're
talking about
but you would agree that any diagnosis
in the dsm would not meet any particular
legal standard that is correct there's
in fact a statement in dsm at the very
beginning that says it in so many words
that no diagnosis
equates to any particular legal
conclusion
would you agree with me that there's no
memory
disorder that's selective just for
criminal behavior that is correct
now you indicated uh that you diagnosed
mr
barristone with depression disorder and
delusion disorder correct
uh
you would agree with me that depression
disorder does not affect a person's
ability to know right from wrong
well counselor that's a complex question
there are all kinds of of levels of
depression
i diagnosed them with persistent
depressive disorder which used to be
called the dsm-4
dysthymia and prior to that used to be
called minor depression or neurotic
depression it basically is serious
condition it could lead to suicide but
it is not usually accompanied by
psychosis
on the other hand there are major
depression disorders which can involve
psychosis and delusional thinking but
that's not my diagnosis
so in this case your your diagnosis of
depression would not have affected
michael barrasson's ability to know
right from all that is correct
i'm sorry not directly i think the
chronic depression made him more
vulnerable
to be affected by all of these events
but it would not lead directly to his
ability to know right from wrongdoing
do you recall if you ever wrote that in
your report
uh i don't recall that i did
with respect to the delusional disorder
that you discussed uh diagnosing the
defendant with uh you would agree that a
person with delusions
could know right from wrong
correct a person with delusions could
understand the nature and quality of
their actions absolutely anything's
possible and i think you just testified
in response to the last question from mr
balinkis
that it's not clear
whether the delusional disorder in this
case affected mr barriston's ability to
understand the nature and quality of his
actions
correct
now i know you testified to this already
but delusional disorder is a relatively
uncommon psychiatric illness correct
some general
general questions doctor would you agree
with me that two people can have the
same experience but perceive it
differently certainly
you'd agree with me that someone being
mistaken about something is not the same
as someone having a delusion
yes in fact in the definition of
delusion
one of the defining points of delusion
is it's not based on simple ignorance or
on
cultural factors so
just for an example if a child believes
in santa claus
that's not a delusion there's no santa
claus but it's not a delusion because
it's held within the realm of children
if a person believes in god whether or
not god exists is not the point there is
a wide variety of people who believe in
god delusions are idiosyncratic they're
believed by the individual with little
of any evidence and they're held on to
firmly and the final point is the
individual with the delusional disorder
cannot be reasoned out of it simple
mistake or simple ignorance will lead to
conclusion you see something and you
believe that your partner is cheating
you out of money but when you're shown
the books and show them the evidence
you say oh that's not true i was wrong
in a delusional disorder you could put
all the evidence in the world out there
the delusional person will hang on to
his or her delusion
and i think you just use the term
idiosyncratic can you just define kind
of how you use that word for the jury i
forgot the context in which i used it
but idiosyncratic means highly personal
that other people don't quite see it
that way
and i think you used it in the context
of a delusion would be highly
idiosyncratic it would be unique to that
person
it is now the content may not be because
people who have delusions
often have themes which are common
themes
like the theme and delusional disorder
persecutory type the theme that you're
being spied on poisoned uh uh endangered
um set up for murder these are common
kind of themes but each individual who's
delusional will have his or her own
idiosyncratic take on it
doctor would you agree with me that a
person feeling an emotion
is not the same as a delusion
well we all feel emotions of course and
we're not all delusional no no we all
feel emotions and sometimes our emotions
are get us into a great deal of trouble
very common that normal people will
believe that i don't know their
girlfriend cheated on them or their
business partner cheated on them or
their driver cut them off
deliberately this is very common they
may even act on it they may even do
violence however in the long run they
don't persist when they're confronted
with the evidence they will back off
mr barrissone would not back off despite
any evidence and despite the fact that
when i mentioned before about being
spied on he was being spied on i mean
there were cameras out there but that's
not the point he thought that this was a
plot a multi-faceted plot all
designed to bring him down and my
question wasn't necessarily specific to
mr barrissone it was just a general
question that a person feeling an
emotion doesn't necessarily mean that
they're delusional i would hope not i
feel emotions every day
i hope you're not feeling any emotions
with me yet doctor only positive uh and
admiring so i mean that genuinely so let
me ask you some questions about the uh
discovery that you reviewed in this case
and uh your evaluation
you indicated that you had met with mr
barrissone for five meetings correct
and the first meeting was in person the
other four meetings were on zoom correct
do you recall approximately the total
number of hours that those
meetings were
the first the total it totaled a number
of six hours in all it's written on the
first page of my report uh i believe the
first session was two hours and the
others were now reached saturday up to
about six
and your first meeting with him was on
september 6 2019 that's correct
and then
which is just
just just about exactly a month after
the incident almost exactly a month
after yesterday
and then your next meeting with him uh
can you just clarify from your report
whether your next meeting was in march
or april april all the other meetings
were in april okay so on your on the
first page of your report where it says
march 13th that should be april 13th
uh that's a typo okay that's the title
which should be april 6 april 13th april
20th april 27th the reason so much time
went by is i needed more discovery
material so when i had the discovery
material i broke this down into meetings
now for example
after you received the discovery
material i think one of the people you
said you reached out to was ann picardo
correct and you indicated that you
were aware that she was the defendant's
psychotherapist for periods off and on
during the years correct
ms picardo is not a doctor to your
knowledge
to my mouth she's not no she's certainly
not a physician and i'm not sure she has
a phd but and i have not seen her
curriculum vitae as far as i know she is
a psychotherapist
now you didn't review all of the
available discovery in the case did you
was that because it wasn't provided to
you or because you didn't want it or
need it i was choking on it i told mr uh
blinkist please stop i've seen enough
i mean i reach a point where you can get
the pattern of things without seeing
every little thing and that really got
to the whole
point of of mr barrissone's problem he
would dig up every tiny little scrap i
didn't need it and didn't want it
well and i wanted to ask you in
particular about a witness statements i
think you indicated on direct
examination that you reviewed a number
of witness states correct did you
actually listen to the recordings of
those witness statements or did you read
police reports that summarized this read
police reports and might have read a
couple of actual statements but i did
not listen to tape recordings now
and you were aware that there were a
number of people
that were listed in the discovery
uh whose statements were not
summarized in police reports i believe
that's true i'm not absolutely sure
there were a lot of people on the farm
a lot of young people older people on
the phone
so on on the pages in your report where
you
talked about
witness statements starting on page six
those would be summaries based on your
impression of what a police officer
wrote in their report correct for the
purpose of constructing a report it's
important for me to summarize
and hopefully the summary is accurate
but in order to digest all of this kind
of information
put it into a readable form and to
extract the essence of it i will
summarize things also to demonstrate my
understanding so if my understanding is
faulty then you can easily see where my
summary misses the point now obviously a
summary doesn't cover everything
hopefully the summary is accurate so
with the summary that the police officer
wrote in the report was
very short and didn't encompass
everything that was talked about during
the statement you wouldn't know that
that's correct and there are also
multiple police reports
you also indicated and i apologize i
don't know what it was marked as but
that you had re uh reviewed some written
statements from mr barrison yes and i
think you said that was 91 pages that he
provided to you well he provided
thousands of pages and the deal i struck
with mr barrison
i'm putting it kindly i told mr
barriston i'm not even going to look at
it unless you give me the 100 top hits
because i don't want more i don't need
more i don't want more you know such a
thing is so in confusion with too much
material so what he did is he complied
and he gave me a document
which consisted of 91 pages
they're not numbered they're basically
chronological mr blinkist and i went
over them and we developed our own
little base numbering system so that i
have easy reference to them but 91 pages
i think fairly summarizes his concerns
and so that would just be what michael
barason wanted you to know
about his take on what happened within
the confines that you gave him well i
had everything
but i instructed him to do that i didn't
want anymore
and and i i read enough to know how
repetitive this was that i did not need
to know every single post lauren canorac
did every time she used the word threat
every time she used the word multiple
personality every time she used the word
i i wasn't interested in that i'd seen
so much of that that i got the idea and
that i wanted him to summarize also
while it may be a biased summary in the
sense that he chose it it's an important
bias because this is what's important to
him and in my thinking what really
mattered about the discovery is not the
fact of it but what was important to him
about it so by having him digest it i
saw what was important to him
so if he put something into his written
statement that wasn't accurate
that wouldn't matter to you well
in the summer
no record is completely accurate
but
the
my review of the records that i saw and
his summary comported with one another
and it was not really for the truth of
anything i was really saying to him
basically go through these thousands of
pagers
pick out a hundred pages the ones that
most affected you and that's what i was
interested in what most affected him
and that's what he gave me
i guess maybe asking that question in
another way would you agree that if the
information you were provided was
inaccurate that could affect your
diagnosis anything's possible
so for example you were asked on direct
examination about various text messages
and and media documents that mr
barrisson told you about yes and he told
you that
he was aware of those
media posts or those uh text messages
before the shooting incident yes she was
following them avidly and so he was
following them almost in real time you
said in that weeks or week leading up to
the show
consistently following her posts
[Music]
now i'm going to show you in that regard
to find the approach sure
what was referred to as exhibit 200 a
85 doctor got it do you remember that
post
i think i was shown this by your
adversary before this comes under a tab
they know a war is coming and where it
has a
pink highlighter around a certain post
who put that there
well i don't know put it there but it
says author lauren cataract this was on
7 28 19 and we've been a week before the
shooting and the text was they know a
war is coming and your recollection is
that michael barissone gave you this
post in particular and told you that
this informed some of his mental state
this was part of a vast number of things
i've seen that quote and i've seen
similar quotes riddled throughout these
emails but i think you're talking your
testimony on direct correct me if i'm
wrong was that you were
shown this particular text or that this
was a particular one mr barrisson
referred to one of them yes
and that's if you would agree with me
that's on page 18
356 of the records 18
356.
that is a lot of patience do you know
where this post came from doctor
no it looked like no i think she had
instagram as well as facebook i don't
know all the social media she used i
think her primary social media was
facebook she texted she used a lot of
social media but 18 000 pages a lot of
pages even in a case like this
wouldn't it surprise you that this came
from
facebook
sent records and this came from the
actual records facebook ad
who is wrong why would that surprise me
not at all
would it surprise you to know that it's
in a section called
private messages between account holders
i have i i no wouldn't surprise me i
don't know so if michael barisson gave
you this and said he relied on this
posting or text message this isn't
something that would have been public at
the time before the shooting i have no
idea this is one of 18 000 pages most of
it's public and this is something
are you aware whether this is something
that was turned over
by the prosecutor's office to the
defense and discovery of 18 000 pages i
cannot account for each one of those
pages they're in evidence i don't know
anything more about that
and i certainly did not read all 18
thousand pages i'm just checking no will
i and doctor i'm just trying to get to
the heart of
michael barrasson told you things you
didn't verify or corroborate everything
that he told you
i'm sorry corroborate in terms of what
well you said that he told you that he
relied on a number of facebook posts yes
that informed his state of mind
yes
and
you said that he told you about this
particular facebook post as a post that
informed his state of mind before the
shooting one of many many many certainly
i did not believe that a war was coming
and so what i'm asking you is if he
wasn't actually aware of this post
before the shooting
does that affect
your opinion about what he told you no
because he was aware of seventeen
thousand other ones which was similar
i'm just making up that number given
eighteen thousand on that yeah
doesn't change anything
[Music]
you were also asked about uh these posts
and i'm going to show you
what you marked as exhibit 200 a
83.
yes
200 a 81 manifestos
900 e6 i've read these manifestos over
and over again and 900 e7 council these
are the manifestos and i'm not going to
ask you to read them again unless you
want to doctor oh please but you
indicated that those were given to you
or referred to by mr barrison many times
and
you referred to them as the manifestos
yeah they're labeled manifesto i'm not
sure that was her word
well i i now i can't even remember any
longer where this word came from
do you remember when you testified on
direct examination that lauren canaract
called those manifestos i think she did
but i'm not sure would it surprise you
to know that she never used the word
manifesto in her records
doctor this is probably a small
detail for the purposes of what you were
asked to evaluate but on page five of
your report
did you indicate that the
police officers responded to investigate
on wednesday august 7 2019 at 4 30.
excuse me 4 13 p.m
uh yes that's what i wrote and are you
aware that the actual time that they
responded was 213. probably there's a
typo
there's several typos in my report
i'm not going to go through all of them
doctor
but staying on page five
you would agree with me at the bottom of
that page
it's talking about mr goodwin and his
statement
yes
and that leads over onto the top of page
six where there's a block quote of
approximately five lines yes that
actually is in inappropriately
attributed to mr goodwin it's actually
this lieutenant heiner statement that
came from the report
so that's not accurate in your report
now you also uh reviewed a number of
medical records in this case i did and
those would have been ms canorex records
as well as mr barrison's and mr goodman
and mr governments
uh
you indicated
that mr barrissone sustained in a dog
bite on his left eye
i think thigh
and i think it was in his groin area
i might have written that as i recall it
i think it was in this groin area okay
that was gonna be my next question
doctors on page nine
it says he had an apparent dog bite
in his in her left eye you're
embarrassing my typo
i just wanted to make sure you were
looking at the right medical records the
right part of the body right
so the so that the bite as you recall it
was in his in his uh on his leg it was
just not on his eye his groin area
now you were aware as you testified on
direct that
dcp p sent a caseworker to the property
on august 7th correct
and you're aware that the caseworker was
there to investigate a claim of child
neglect that's my understanding child
neglect of child abuse yes now you also
indicated that the report uh was
anonymous
uh were you aware from reviewing the
records that it was actually a report
from safe sport
later i read that initiated with safe
sport which is the sporting
uh governing body and i know as a fact
everybody in this profession belongs to
safe sport most legitimate people belong
to safe sport and it's my belief that
lauren cataract filed a report with safe
sport to uh
file a report against mr barry's own
making more claims by the vehicle of
safe sport what i meant by anonymous is
that the actual complainant wasn't
identified as lord cataract or anybody
else it's my experience with child
protective as they do not reveal the
names of complainants that's very common
but i i do believe it was filed via safe
sport it's by understanding that lauren
canorack had reported
you don't have to say
doctors thank you
but are you aware that the complaint was
actually against michael barisson and ms
gray
yes i think so
sorry to start choking
now you indicated earlier i think that
you summarized some of the witness
statements in your report i did
and
i'm gonna show you
one of the
one of the remarks
this doesn't have an evidence sticker on
it
but if i could refer to this as s-147
it is marked for identification show it
to council please
doctor i know you said there was a lot
of discovery in this case so i won't ask
you if that
is definitely one of the reports that
you read
let me just see if i can readily lay my
hands on that
it's a
report from morris county prosecutors
office by sasha gold i do remember that
name
and i did review that i think yes
and doctor i'm going to refer you to
sasha ghoul there were two ghouls
investigators so i remember this is
sasha ghoul it was a male ghoul as well
that's right
and doctor i'm going to refer you to
page five of that report
right approximately
i would say two-thirds to three-quarters
of the way down
it's actually the third paragraph from
the bottom that starts with gray stated
that on today's date yes
and do you see the sentence that says it
was learned that someone from her house
reported allegations of abuse against
gray's children by verizon correct
and this is in reference to
detective gould's summary
of her interview with ms ms mary haskins
gray correct
and you relied on
that summary in in formulating or adding
information to your report well
um
just you said this
yes that's right
this report by investigator gould she
spoke to both mr barriston and miss gray
this statement specifically relates to
this this grade um and uh
i just want to identify the statement so
could you repeat your question sure and
just before we do that you just said
that
detective gould interviewed mr
barrissone and ms gray but i think you
meant she interviewed mr goodwin mr
goodwin sorry mr goodwin
right mr goodwin in this grade
so the sentence i was referring to was
it was learned that someone from her
house reported allegations of abuse
against gray's children by verison
uh yes
and then if i direct your attention to
your report
page eight
and i'll refer to your report as s 423 i
think it's the same as
the one the defendant marked yes
i have
a pg
of my report of your report yes i have
it
and does the very last full sentence on
that page say
it was learned that someone had reported
allegations of sexual abuse against miss
gray's children by mr bearson correct
so you'd agree with me the only
difference between the sentence you
wrote in your report about ms gray's
interview and the sentence that sasha
gould wrote in her report about miss
gray's interview is that you added the
word sexual before abuse
oh
um
yes this does not say sexual
i think that came from something else
but i don't remember this does not say
sexual here so
beginning when you say this doesn't say
sexual what are you referring to your
honor the uh statement by investigator
gould
that i was quoting
said abuse does not say sexual abuse
okay
so when you indicated earlier that you
summarized certain witness statements in
your report
i think you said that that was to give
your understanding of what some of the
witnesses said
as it may have pertained to your
ultimate opinions yeah yes correct it
allows you to point out the error that
she did not say sexual so i i laid out
my understanding which in terms of the
word sexual was not correct
so you added the word sexual into your
report where ms gray never said that in
her statement i don't know if she ever
said it or never said it but that
doesn't appear in that particular
statement and i did not add it
deliberately and that's because you
never listened to her statement or
watched her statement correct
so you added it perhaps inadvertently i
guess you're saying
based on something else you saw in the
case i think so yes
in fact in those
written
statements of michael barissone
does he continually say
that
dcp and p was there for something
related to sexually i think so
so michael barasone told you in his
written statement
or wrote in his written statement that
the worker was there to investigate
sexual abuse
and then you adopted that in your report
not really uh it's my experience
counseling working with dyphus over many
years
now d c p and p
is that they provide minimal information
and they will just simply say a
complaint has been filed they won't say
by whom they often don't even say the
type of complaint and i don't know why
sexual crept into this certainly doesn't
reflect what investigator gould said it
does reflect what barristone said i
really don't know the answer to that but
i do know that some kind of complaint
was filed and i don't know who initiated
it it came via the sport safe
professional organization but i don't
know who initiated it mr
barrissone assumed that it was lauren
cataract
one more attack against him but i have
no way of knowing that and i think you
said you don't know where that word
sexual or where the sexual abuse came
from why it got inserted here correct
but
you would agree with me based on what we
just discussed the division
of child protection and permanency dcpmp
was not there to investigate sexual
abuse i don't know i'd have to read go
through this again maybe in the break
and see the statements that came
directly from the investigator if there
was a statement directly from the
investigator i'm not sure i saw anything
from the investigator what if i told you
that that investigator testified in
court earlier in this trial and said
that she was not there to investigate
sexual abuse i will accept that uh that
uh
assertion
would you also accept the representation
that the safe sport records of the
initial complaint do not reference
sexual abuse if that's your
assertion i will accept it
so where you indicated that you didn't
know where the word sexual came from
you're also acknowledging that that is
in the defendant's written statements
that he gave to you correct and i might
have conflated it in doing my summary of
the report this is really as i explained
one of the reasons i lay out my summary
so that if i am an error of anything it
can easily be picked up by you on
cross-examination
so you're putting
things that are intentionally wrong into
your report so i can catch them on
cross-examination
is that what you just said that's one of
the most bizarre things i've ever been
asked no i lay out my thinking so that
you have the opportunity to examine the
basis of my report and to question me if
i'm in error about one of the bases as
you have here
i'm not trying to trick you and i'm not
trying to trick you either doctor
uh
now you indicated in your report on page
14
that michael barrasson told you the last
thing he remembers is information from
the social worker cool
do you recall in that
written
statement that he gave you the 91 pages
that he said
that there were two or three images
blurry at best until being unloaded from
the ambulance at morristown
if you direct me to the page sure doctor
i
i have it marked as the very last page
in those writings okay and just so the
record is clear i'm referring to what
i've marked as s40 s and 440
for identification
i have it i call it page 91.
and doctor i'm specifically looking at
the end of that paragraph and you would
agree with me page 91 is the last page
michael barissone wrote that he gave to
you
in that so-called hundred page packet
which actually were 91 pages yes what it
says is the last two images i saw before
the lights went out it's actually before
that doctor what i'm referring to it
says i remember being at my desk i have
two or three images blurry at best until
being unloaded from an ambulance at
morristown
yes i have
i remember being at my desk i have two
yes
did you ask him what those two or three
images that he remembered about the
incident work i did and i have an a red
x over that which is my notation for
meaning he could provide no further
information
on that particular four sentences i
place the red x when i go through a
statement which means you can provide
nothing else so you did ask him and he
responded he didn't remember what that
meant correct
and that's that's not in your report i
don't think i missed that correct i
didn't have these 91 pages i had 18 000
pages when i did my report and i've
already told you i did not read all 18
000 pages i'm sorry doctor that maybe i
wasn't clear
you
you didn't indicate in your report that
you asked him the question specifically
about the two or three things that he
remembered that were blurry and he
couldn't remember correct
you would agree with me that a person
who is
feigning amnesia may spontaneously
confess to something
can you repeat the question sure you
would agree with me that someone's who's
feigning amnesia may spontaneously
confess anything can happen if the word
you're saying is made anything may
happen
and i'm specifically
referencing in the dsm
where it talks about feigning amnesia
doesn't it indicate that an individual
who's gaining amnesia may spontaneously
confess sure that can happen
and these
statements that mr barristone wrote that
you indicated you relied on
were you with him when he wrote those i
was not
do you recall approximately when you
asked for those to be written
um
it was some time after my last interview
in april of 2020 when i i told
mr bulinkus that i had so much material
that i insisted that he ask his client
to prepare a digest for me so you asked
him to write those after your last
interview with him correct and i said no
more than 100 pages
and when he
protested i said no more than 100 pages
if there's anything more than 100 pages
i'm not going to read it do you recall
approximately when those 91 pages were
produced to you uh sometime after my
last interview in
april of 2020
and you just indicated that after you
got those uh you reviewed them yes and
you indicated that at least with respect
to the comments about two to three
images that were blurry in his mind you
asked him about those and he didn't
remember all i have is an x here
i underlined many things i do that when
i in red when i do an interview i had an
x here which meant he gave me no further
information
so you interviewed him or examined him
again after that last meeting of april
that's listed in your report um
that's a good question i did not uh i
did not
that may have come
i might have
put that together with some of the
original
uh
material that he submitted
so it's possible you didn't ask him
about the two to three parts of the
event that he did remember even if they
were certainly possible yes
doctor moving on to your diagnosis
specifically the diagnosis for
delusional disorder
i think you indicated that a delusion is
a false belief
yes a false belief
not based on simple ignorance
not held by any particular culture of a
subculture and not amenable to
reasonable change did you define the
term delusion in your report at all
i said probably i did
it starts with false belief
but with those with those caveats
yes on page 18
of my report this is in the summary
section
where i wrote delusional disorder is a
relatively uncommon but severe
psychiatric illness the disorder
involves psychotic thinking
and a break with reality
that's the same thing psychotic thinking
in a break with reality delusional
disorder is related to schizophrenia
which is a much more common condition in
schizophrenia the individual displays a
wide range of serious symptoms including
hallucinations agitation
disordered thought process and delusions
however
i'm adding in delusional disorder the
major symptoms involve delusions not
these other things so in schizophrenia
you have a grab bag full of serious
symptoms in delusional disorder you just
have the delusions so it's a part of
schizophrenia
um now you well i'm not
my question was just whether you defined
it and i think you did answer that well
i haven't finished the definition i
didn't ask you to define it i asked you
if you did define it yes and i was
reading in my definition okay i didn't
ask for that okay thank you doc
what in particular
is is michael barisson's specific
delusion
uh that lauren counteract is bound and
determined to destroy him and kill him
when did that delusion start
i can't say exactly probably in the
summer of 2019.
and what uh
specific evidence do you rely on to show
that that was the onset of the delusion
that lauren kanarek was
i don't want to paraphrase i'm sorry i
didn't get the exact words you used well
the posts
and his deteriorating mental state
and their deteriorating relationship
so potentially the posts that michael
barrasson told you about when you met
with him correct some of which we've
established he didn't have before the
shooting
judge one not some
yeah you're just one
well i only address one judge
but if you have if you have others then
you can address them but you only
addressed one i didn't go through them
all on the brink to be candid judge i
understand
but what you did go through what's on
the record is one
so doctor my question was
you indicated that you based your
opinion about the onset of the delusions
and the delusional diagnosis
on
the existence of these social media or
facebook posts well yes on the
deteriorating relationship
between cataract and barrister
the things they were saying to each
other and particularly primarily on
these posts and texts
and you didn't indicate in your report
specifically when you determined
the onset of the delusions i think i
mentioned in the report that it started
somewhere in 2019 i think after she
returned from the farm in florida and
moved back to the farm in new jersey
they had had normal problems before that
time he said normal
landlord-tenant-type problems but after
she returned things took a decided turn
for the worse
so if i'm reading your report right are
you talking about on page 16
where you indicate mr barristone's
relationship with lauren canreck and her
family began to quickly deteriorate in
the spring of 2019 correct
so you wrote that there because you
determined that the
delusions began then
well they
they never begin at one particular time
delusions develop and if you look at the
history of the delusion and you go
backward in time what you'll usually
find are suspicions
and distrust
and feelings about bad will these are
all within the normal intercourse
between people but then they get more
out of hand and the
ideas become less and less plausible and
more and more eccentric and more and
more idiosyncratic i think that by the
time spring of 2019
laura cataract started saying things
which were unmoored from reality
unmoored from what was actually
happening
and michael
barrison was more and more believing the
things that she was saying
and you'd agree with me that
the criteria or symptom for
delusional disorder would be that the
delusion has existed for a period of one
month or longer correct
and so you what you're saying today is
even though you didn't determine
specifically whether it was before a
month before the shooting that that's
your opinion that it did exist yes it's
somewhere in the spring of 2019 it's
very hard to put a specific date on it
but the reason the dsm puts that proviso
in is it's to rule out an instance where
somebody suddenly claims
that all of a sudden today i became
delusional about you that's not the way
the disorder happens it percolates and
develops over time so this is a very
typical development of the delusional
disorder over time
doctor you testified on direct
examination that
mr barrissone was depressed and
preoccupied
with uh
ms canara
and you
based that in part on
review of the
various facebook posts and social media
posts that he told you that he was
reviewing well that statements by other
witnesses miss piccardo mr
tarshiss mary gray haskins ruth cox some
of the young people on the farm justin
harden i can't name all of them but
there were a lot of people who were
interviewed who were seeing the same
thing and felt helpless to do anything
about it everybody seemed to see a train
wreck coming but nobody seemed to know
what to do about it and they were all uh
preoccupied with what was going on here
between themselves and ms cannery well
not the way he was they were concerned
that's small potatoes they were
concerned i'm concerned about a lot of
things i'm sure you're concerned about a
lot of things that's not the same as
preoccupied preoccupied is having a
thought in your head that you cannot get
out of your head no matter what
that's the delusion
so if if some of those witnesses let's
say had testified that they were
terrified
or that they were scared or that they
were preoccupied with everything going
on
does that mean they were delusional too
no it depends they were certainly
preoccupied and frightened because the
farm was falling apart this is their
place of residence
and their place of employment
and they were all dedicated very uh very
strongly to a sport in which they shared
a common love and they also shared a
great deal of affection for michael
barrisson that came out
they saw everything unraveling
in front of their eyes and felt helpless
to do anything about it this had to do
with mary haskins gray and ruth cox and
i think that's one of the reasons ruth
cox came to visit i don't remember
exactly had to do with stephen tarshish
had to do with justin harden people saw
from that point of view that things were
going very badly and they did not know
how to intervene
now you didn't review all of their
statements
counselor i would still be in my office
today if i were reviewing every one of
the statements i took what i thought was
a fair sampling
so if somebody said something different
than what you just testified to
that could affect your opinion it has to
do with the overall thing if one
kid on the farm said gee things look
pretty happy that's not going to change
the overwhelming weight of evidence what
if all of the what if all of the people
felt the same way and expressed their
concerns the same way that michael
barisson did well
if you're saying that they're that
they're
own fears or their preoccupations were
somehow less than michael barrasson well
it's it's
this is sort of a hypothetical thing but
if you're saying if
if
justin harden said i felt personally
threatened that she was going to kill me
if stephen tarshish's attorney said i
was personally threatened that she was
going to kill me well that might be
different but nobody said anything like
that they were concerned about
barrister's welfare there wasn't anybody
else there that felt personally and
directly threatened by cataract and
goodwill based on your review
of what you did review that's all i have
and when you're given everything correct
i was given more than everything you had
access to everything
and you chose god help me yes i had
access to 18 000 pages
and it isn't just a question of reading
18 000 pages and writing a bill for 18
000 pages i'm not going to do that it's
not necessary
in doing a review of medical records
it's not necessary to do each one things
become very duplicative and after a
point especially when you're
experiencing reading records as i think
i am a pattern emerges
now that doesn't mean that on tuesday
one day somebody said things look pretty
good that wouldn't change anything the
overall picture was clear people on the
farm were concerned about the welfare of
michael barrasso when they saw the man
they really cared for deteriorating but
they were not concerned about their
personal safety it was only barrisol who
was afraid
that lauren canarac was going to kill
him he was the only one that was afraid
correct
that he was going to be killed by
cataract now moving on uh to the
question i had about um
some of the information that mr
barristone was collecting
uh you indicated that he produced
i'm sorry
it's about i know we started a little
bit late today so i wanted to go a
little bit over but
if if if you're going to finish up
within five minutes
or ten minutes i'll continue but if it's
going to be longer i want to give the
jury there
fairly right here's a good time
yeah all right i'm getting it
all right
that cinches it then doctor will break
for lunch all right very good enjoy your
lunch ladies and gentlemen we'll see you
around
20 of 2.
doctor you can leave all your papers
you